συφιακής πολιτικής στην προσπάθεια υπου κάνει για να φέρει την τεχνολογία μέσα στις διαδικασίες όλου
του δημοσί το αντριάνιο κλαίος του περάσεναπε τον μυάλλον ποτε να σχολεθεί με την πολιτηκή
έρασε και έφιεν αμέσως ένθα ϊμον καλός πολιτικός σας έγινε προτάσει δεν μου έγινε κάποια
πρόταση συζητήσεις έχω βρέθει πολλς φορές επίσην η πρόταση δεν έχωαποκανέναν όμως η πραγματικότηι ότι
και ότι και ναγίνει στιν πολιτική είναι νομίζω θελεις αλλά αλλές ικανότητες τις οποίες δεν
τεσέχο και άλλες αντοχές ίσως που επίσηζανται σε έχου νομίζωαυτό που κάπνο τώρα είναι κάτι
το οποίον μου αρέσει κάτι που νιώθο ότι μπορώ να προσφέρω νομίζω έχει καλύτερους απόμένα
για την πολιτική έχουμε σήμερα τ στι λεπικοινωνίες που πρέπει να έχουμε στη χώρα μας
υπάρχει ακόμα δελτίως να ξπεριθώρειο βελτίωσις για όλα υπάρχει αλλά θεωρώ ότι έχουμε τις καλύτερες
τηλεπικοινώνιες που θα μπορούσε να είχαμε και ο λόγος γιατί το λεόδεν το λέω εγώ
αυτό αν δείται τα στατιστικά τα οποία οβγαίνουν από την ευρωπακί ένωση θα δίται ότι
η κύπρος είνα η πρώτη χώρας στην ευρωπαϊκή ένωση που είχε εκατό τις εκατόν καλυψει
στο φαιυτζή μέχρει τέλως του σέίσε ένα χρόνο θα είναι η πρώτη χώρα στην ευρωποκινένωση
που θα έχει εκατόν τις εκατόν καλυψεις εοπτικές ίνς είχαμε για δύο χρόνια συνέχει για
το γρηγορότερο δείκτιον κινητής την ευρώπη αυτές είναι προτιές ποςεξε δεν είναι να μαστε λίγον
στον μέσων όρον όπως σε πολλά άλλα θέματα τεχνολογίας θεωρούμε επίτευγμα να είμαστε στο μέσον
ώρο να μην είμαστε τελευταίοι ισύητα στις τηλεπικοινωνίες έχει διασφαλίσει